on récolte l'eau d'érable depuis des
siècles les autochtones le faisais même
avant l'arrivée des européens est
aujourd'hui la production de sirop
d'érable c'est une industrie majeure
dans l'est du canada pourtant on
comprend encore mal le phénomène de la
koulik et vous allez voir l'érable est
loin d'avoir livré tous ses secrets
où
[Musique]
une rumeur synonyme de printemps des
gouttes d'eau d'érable résonne dans les
chaudières quand le temps se réchauffe
la coulée arrive fidèles il suffit d'en
tailler et l'eau sucrée est au rendez
vous mais pour les chercheurs le
phénomène n'est pas si limpide
moi j'ai beaucoup de visiteurs européens
qui viennent même des américains qui
connaissent pas vraiment le processus de
la couler de l'eau d'érable et on pose
plein de questions et je suis toujours
un peu embarrassé quand je réponds bah
on ne sait pas vraiment
ce que vous avez commencé à vous êtes
les plus grands producteurs de sirop
d'érable au monde et vous ne comprenez
pas encore tout à fait le mécanisme de
la couler de l'eau d'érable
on a beau avoir grandi en s'abreuvant à
la chaudière chaque printemps
cette eau sucrée suscite bien des
interrogations
on peut comprendre pourquoi certains
arbres de ne plus de volume que d'autres
et pourquoi certains abandonnent plus de
sucre que d'autres dans une même journée
le volume va changer le taux de sucre va
changer chez eux mêmes arbres dans une
même journée ça va changer entre les
jours d'une saison qui savent changer
entre les saisons
[Musique]
avec ses étudiants au doctorat le
professeur christian messier a donc
décidé de se pencher sur plusieurs de
ces questions
c'est ce que si on comprend mieux
comment se fait ce mouvement d'où là on
va pouvoir éventuellement peut-être
guidée au niveau de la récolte des
pratiques qui vont être durable qui vont
pas avoir d'effet sur les rames ou sur
l'écosystème parce que là actuellement
on récolte de l'eau puis on n'a pas
vraiment de bonnes données pour savoir
est-ce qu'on a récolte rhône à l'école
pas c est ce qu on pourrait peut-être
antoyé différemment
les chercheurs s'intéressent entre
autres à l'une des grandes questions
existentielles entourant l'érable d'où
vient son nom
est-ce que c'est majoritairement de
l'eau qui provient des racines qu'on
récolte ou si c'est de l'eau qui est
déjà présente dans l'arbre à la fin de
l'hiver
ce sont toutes des questions qu'on a eu
aucune réponse pour l'instant
au printemps c'est l'alternance de gel
et de dégel qui provoque le mouvement de
l'eau c'est pendant la période de geler
la nuit quand l'oeil des cristaux de
glace qui se forme dans le bois une
pression négative et donc l'eau est
absorbée dans larmes montent dans la rue
un mouvement ascendant qu'on mesure et
l'on pense qu'une certaine quantité
d'eau dans le sol qui vient recharger
notre et abl d'habitude c'est les fuites
qui provoquent le mouvement d'eau qui
vont tirer l'eau vers le haut dans
l'arbre grâce à leur transpiration les
mouvements de l'eau à l'intérieur de
l'arve c'est très mystérieux parce qu'il
ya beaucoup d'armes dans lesquels lieu
de noms qui circulent quand ya pas de
feu outre les râbles ce club sélect
d'arbres qui donne de l'eau au printemps
comprend entre autres les boulots et les
noyer mais leur sève est beaucoup moins
sucré que celle des érables
pour suivre le parcours de l'eau dans
les arbres au printemps de drôles de
seringue ont été plantés dans les
érables elles permettent d'injecter du
deutérium un isotope stable de
l'hydrogène ça se trouve être comme de
l'eau c'est juste qu'elle est un peu
plus lourde donc c'est pas toxique du
tout pour les humains nous qui le
manipule on y pour l'arbre dans lequel
on va injecter le deutérium mais qu'on
fait des analyses en laboratoire comme
ce tour le est légèrement plus lourde on
est capable de la retrouver le deutérium
est injectée as tu es endroits dans le
sol pour atteindre les racines mais
aussi près du sommet car l'eau circule
jusque dans les branches les plus fines
à la cime des arbres
on prend des échantillons de la cfa
chaque jour qui va sortir de l'entente
on va envoyer sur laboratoire ça va nous
permettre de savoir est ce que l'eau
qu'on a injecté nos différentes parties
s'est rendu et si elle s'est rendue à
nos trente ans il a pris combien de
temps des échantillons sont aussi
prélevées à différents endroits le long
du tronc pour mesurer le taux de sucre
depuis toujours on en taille à une
hauteur qui facilite le travail des
acériculteurs mais est ce vraiment le
meilleur endroit
on soupçonne fortement que c'est plus
sucrées quand on monte plus honorable
mais pas taclé - dont par contre c'est
trouver peut-être moteur qui optimale
qui maximise à la fois les ce qu'on
récolte et la quantité d'eau
[Musique]
depuis le temps qu'on fait du sirop au
royaume de l'érable il ya quand même
quelques certitudes pour que ça cool on
sait qu'il faut que le mercure plonge
sous le point de congélation la nuit et
remonte au dessus de zéro le jour sauf
que parfois on a des températures bien
qu'ils sont encore propice à la coulée
mais certains on arrête de couler on
sait pas pourquoi exactement c'est comme
si il y avait un certain volume d'eau à
donner puis quand le volume d'eau et
donnez-leur arrête de couler pour
arriver à percer ce mystère là il faut
fouiller la question sous différents
angles par exemple des thermomètres
mesure la température dans l'arbre à
différentes hauteurs et les écarts
peuvent être grands donc ici vous avez
le premier terme au mal qui est inséré à
l'intérieur du tronc on va voir la
température au niveau de l'an taillé
dans le bois on un deuxième thermomètre
qui est installé beaucoup plus haut dans
l'asthme et aux mesures comme seul le
gradien de jeunes internes de l'arbre
négocié les températures devraient
encore dix ans au hockey
de tout temps ces écarts ont existé mais
il est d'autant plus important de
comprendre leur impact dans le contexte
des changements climatiques dans ce coin
de l'érablière des sondes mesure les
flux de sève un pluviomètre recueille
aussi long de la coulée et prend une
mesure en continu toutes les 30 minutes
une station météo relais des données sur
les conditions locales l'analyse de
toutes ces informations permettra
d'établir un modèle clair donc pas de
mieux comprendre ce qui se passe et à
plus long terme aussi de pouvoir mieux
envisager ce qui va se passer à l'avenir
avec les changements climatiques au
pouvoir s'adapter à ça et faire en sorte
que l'activité puisse rester pérenne
dans le temps et changement climatique
ça change tellement les conditions on
voit les périodes de coulée qui était
assez stable avant plus longues lens
moment on voit des périodes où les la
coulée est réservé à deux trois épisodes
très intense de couler
où
pour assurer la pérennité des érablières
il faudra aussi faire une plus grande
place aux espèces compagnes
même si ça va à l'encontre de certaines
idées reçues mot de tout temps on
modiste des sapins dans ton aimerait
bien enlève les ça diminue de la coulée
pourra voir à moitié des érables depuis
que ce très jeune quand il y avait des
sapins en entaille au printemps tôt au
printemps les armes entourée de sa peine
ne coulait pas tandis qu'un arbre qui
est entouré de sapins couler mais les
gens avaient jamais vraiment mesuré
qu'est ce qui se passe sur l'ensemble de
la saison christian messier et son
équipe l'ont fait mais ce qui est arrivé
qui nous a surpris c'est que les rampes
qui était en milieu ensoleillé a été
coulé beaucoup plus tôt que les érables
qui est entouré de conifères et qu'à la
fin il y avait aucune différence en
termes de volume d'eau ces nouvelles
connaissances pourraient contribuer à
changer les façons de faire et à rendre
les érablières plus résiliente ont
nettoyé les érablières on enlever toutes
les autres espèces on faisait un espèce
de chant monoculture érables aujourd'hui
on sait qu'il faut laisser cette
biodiversité là on sait qu'il faut avoir
d'autres espèces pour pour la qualité
des sols la diversité faunique aussi
donc pour protéger l'érable et la santé
de l'écosystème d'avoir cette diversité
là
si les acériculteurs se donne tant de
mal au printemps c'est pour récolter une
infime partie des réserves de sucre
fabriqué est emmagasinée par les érables
on sait que les réserves dans les arbres
c'est très important parce que ça permet
par exemple si vous avez une année avec
un insecte qui vient vous défoliés mes
larmes peut recréer des feuilles il a
besoin de ces réserves mais les
chercheurs se sont demandé quand si
sucre remonte il avec une équipe de
scientifique le professeur sylvain de la
grange à participer à une découverte qui
a permis de dater le sucre d'érable que
l'on récolte la méthode pour y arriver
est pour le moins insolite dans les
années 60/70 beaucoup de tests
nucléaires qui ont augmenté la
radioactivité dans l'air est à partir de
ce moment là quand on les a arrêtés ces
tests là la radioactivité baisse tout
doucement d'une quantité connue chaque
année donc quand on regarde une molécule
dessus qui a été fabriqué par l'arbre a
été fabriqué du co2 qui contient une
radioactivité de cette année là et
chaque année elle en perd un petit peu
donc en regardant la radioactivité qui
est dans le sucre on est capable de
savoir il a été produit dans cette année
là résultat les secrets qu'on recueille
dans l'eau d'érable ont en moyenne entre
3 et 4 ans
ce que ça nous dit c'est qu'il ya quand
même déçu qu'ils vont être chercher
beaucoup plus loin dans le dans l'arbre
et qui sont des ceux qui ont été
produits cinq six voire dix ans avant le
moment où les entailles notre sirop ne
date pas d'hier non c'est ça aussi frais
que ça
le sucre cadeau de l'érable ravi les
palais depuis des générations en persan
peu à peu ses secrets les chercheurs
veulent ainsi s'assurer qu'on puisse le
déguster encore longtemps
[Musique]